we're going back to the old double deuce
the crew of apollo 22 aka jamestown 2
and its crew of three that have all for
very different reasons
never return to the moon hey guys pete
here
this will be my breakdown for all
mankind season 2 episode 4.
the episode is titled pathfinder which
is after
nasa's next generation space shuttle
which was teased on twitter about a week
ago
as a warning this video will contain
spoilers if you haven't watched
episode 4 yet and with that out of the
way let's get into it
so at the baldwin house at breakfast we
see that karen did pick up on the fact
that ed hasn't been back to the moon
because he made a promise to himself
never to leave her and then kelly alone
again
karen runs through the options and lands
on pathfinder a test pilot's dream and
you gotta give it to her she knows her
husband
he's reluctant taken by surprise but
she's right and she's insistent
it's not until later when he looks at
the pathfinder model he has in his
office
that we see him light up and know he's
going back to space
after that we find gordo trying out his
new space suit
and we see that he's still anxious about
this whole process
after they put his helmet on he freaks
out and we see that he's out of it
and his vision starts to look a little
bit distorted he doesn't respond to the
text when they talk to him
and ultimately he takes off and we see
him in the bathroom where he breaks down
it's clear that what happened during the
apollo 22 mission
is still weighing heavily on his mind at
the outpost ed tells danny and gordo
about his return
after he congratulates them on doing a
great job on their proficiency test they
laugh and joke
around but everyone is happy he made
this decision
the whole crew is going back if not
together and then ed notices that
something is off with gordo
he tells him what happened with the
helmet assures them that he didn't tell
anybody else about it
and they're supportive there's concern
but it looks like at least right now
they think that gordo can pull it off
that he can pull himself together
and things will go differently this time
danny's also got something on her mind
and she tells them that she has to go
visit clayton's sister and she's just
not looking forward to it
she does go there and it's tense they
don't have a good relationship
there's definitely tension between these
two and through their conversation we
begin to understand
why danny's doing her best to make peace
that's why she's there
and the sister is just not open to it
she tells her that she knows what really
happened on the moon
and basically says that dany's allowed
nasa to use her
make her a laughing stock and that she
put up with it in order to save a white
man's career
dany makes the distinction here that
this was a member of her crew
her friend a good man and that his skin
color didn't really have anything to do
with it at the time
and from there things get personal the
sister says that dany is the one who
filled clay's head with all that
patriotic crap
and that that experience which he went
through for nothing
in the sister's opinion is the reason
why he's no longer with them
and what's more when she hears that
danny's going back to the moon the
sister points out the fact that hey look
you're spending all this money to go up
there and do that when there's things
that are more important
like if there was more money in the va
maybe clayton would still be there
and it's a pretty well reasoned argument
on both sides that leaves an
impression on danny neither person is
wrong from their own point of view
and that makes it really resonate on an
emotional level the scene works
and it hits pretty hard and is up there
with ed's meltdown in the last episode
ed's trying to get out of his office
because it's his last day
and danny comes in to see him she's
decided that she wants a command slot
and she's counting on the connection
they have to make this happen
this clearly makes that uncomfortable
and he doesn't want to have anything to
do with it he just wants to get out of
the office
but she makes a good case for herself
and she stands her ground
he won't commit at this moment but he's
definitely thinking about it and when he
goes into the meeting
and finds out that the soviets have
agreed to the handshake
and space plan it works out pretty well
for him now payne is not into the idea
at all
he's hoping for somebody else someone he
can champion to the president
and he's concerned about what happened
in apollo 22
and there might be more going on there
but he doesn't really get a chance to
argue because everyone else that's there
that's worked with danny
is immediately on board with what ed's
talking about
there's a consensus that she's the right
choice and another thing that's working
to her advantage is that
one of the main reasons they didn't want
to do this mission with the soviets is
because they didn't want to let them see
their new technology they didn't want
them to see the space shuttle
ellen had brought up the idea that they
could use one of the apollo spacecraft
to avoid this
and of course that's where dany's
experience is
and bradford also makes a great point
that the soviets have always been
using the us's troubled history with
race against them
and he makes it clear that he's on board
for this he wants to see it happen
and if payne has any problems taking
this to the president then he'll get on
the phone with the secretary of defense
who will back him
up in the end it works out but payne
does come and visit ed at his office
basically calling him out for
blindsiding him before he leaves his
post
the next time we see him we see ed
getting ready for his first day back as
an astronaut
it's clear that he's in his element he's
in a good mood eating his literal
wheaties
he goes out and decides that he's gonna
drive his corvette to work and of course
that breaks down as soon as he gets it
out of the garage
this was definitely a funny scene to
watch it was a nice montage of him
getting ready it kind of got you pumped
up for the whole idea
and then you couldn't help but laugh
when you see it break down
he's on his way to meet with biscotti
and sally ride they're his crew
we saw him tell this to biscotti earlier
after he gave him a hat to put on to
cover his red hair and decided that that
would work
of course in our timeline sally ride was
the first american woman
in space he takes them to see pathfinder
for the first time
and the show managed to put together a
pretty awesome reveal here
they cut the scenes of them going to see
the new shuttle with danielle going to
look at her
ship it's the past and the future right
there and the way they cut things
together it's really uplifting and you
can't help but be kind of odd when you
see them arrive at their ships
it's one of those things that this show
does really well
we hear ed talking to biscotti and ryde
and he tells them why they're there
gives them a little bit of a pep talk
and the whole thing ends with him saying
let's go make history
and i've watched this sequence several
times while writing this script
and it hit me every single time at the
outpost we catch up with gordo watching
nikolai volkov versus sergeant slaughter
on the tv
he's getting ready to go meet ed having
his lunch and when he looks at his soda
he sees that there's ants all over it
and it looks like he's hallucinating
he definitely thinks he's hallucinating
and then we get clued into what's really
going on when karen walks over and
sprays them with ant spray which felt
pretty 80s i can't imagine someone
spraying that just holding up the menu
to keep it off the food and out of
everyone's face at the bar
when he does meet ed he tells him about
it and he freaks out he tells him the
story about his father how tough the guy
was
all the things that he'd been through
and about seeing him laying flat on his
back on his bed in the hospital with
cancer and seeing so much fear in his
eyes seeing him scared for the first
time
and how he couldn't take seeing that he
says maybe the fear was with him all
along
but he was too weak to fight against it
anymore at that point
and that's fairly revealing with what's
going on inside gordo's head
and really ed doesn't know what to do
with it he really doesn't know how to
react in a way that's useful
so he takes the harsher route and tells
him to be a man
basically forget about that you're not
hallucinating
the real problem here is that you're
being weak you're an astronaut
you willingly sit on top of a rocket
that's made of
flammable fuel so be a man already and
it's the kind of scene that makes you
wonder like what are they trying to say
here is gordo sick
we don't really know what really did
happen with gordo on the moon we do know
that he went to see a therapist when he
came back but we really don't know if
this was just stress related or if there
was more to it
so i'm curious because the gordo stuff
has been entertaining
but he also has all the makings of a
tragic character here
i mean if nothing else we see that he's
got ptsd from what happened the last
time he went to the moon so i'm curious
to see where they're taking this
character
he pulls himself together and they each
pilot their own jet
and in the process ed decides that he
wants to make him feel better i guess
so he initiates what is essentially a
drill of them pretending that they're in
a dog fight
gordo is able to rise to the occasion
he's able to chase ed down
get him in a simulated target lock and
this seems to make him feel better
but at the same time one of ed's engines
catches on fire
and he has to eject from the plane it
was kind of a weird turn i'm not really
sure
where that's going it turns out to be a
cool little cliffhanger that makes you
wonder
and i will come back to this again in a
minute so some other things that were
going on
in the episode beyond just following the
apollo 22 astronauts we do also get some
time with ellen
she goes to see pain about the mars
mission being put on the back burner
and he does a pretty good job of
explaining the politics of things to her
he tells her how he did a favor that
went against nasa's short-term
interests as a way to get that same
politician he helped
introduce the bill that allows nasa to
license their tech to private firms
this is an important divergence as i
mentioned in my timeline video
and he stresses how that's going to
allow them to be self-funded within 10
years
and thus free them up from the whims of
congress
we learned that he's actually passionate
about space and he says that people hate
politicians but they're the ones that
make all of this possible
it definitely adds some depth to the
character but it's also worth noting
that he emphasized that they need a
republican president to win in the next
election cycle to keep him in his place
it's also noticeable that he drives home
this idea that the trick is not to lose
track of who you really
are considering ellen's situation we do
see her at home
where larry encourages her to open all
the mail that she missed while she was
on the moon
in that we finally find out where pam
went after the end of season one
she's teaching writing in austin and she
sent a book of poetry
asking if ellen can guess which poem is
about her
seems like this opens the door to a
return for pam
and it brings up a question about a
connection with our timeline
i mentioned sally ride earlier as a part
of ed's pathfinder crew
and the fact that she was the first
woman that the u.s sent to space
she's also recognized as the first lgbt
person in space but it wasn't something
that was known about until after her
death
like ellen she was married to a man in
the space program
an astronaut though but her real-life
partner turned out to be a woman that
she spent 27 years of her life with
she kept her personal life private and
the relationship wasn't acknowledged
until after she passed away
this is definitely something to keep in
mind when we think about where ellen's
story might be going
we also saw tracy taking off going back
for six months on the moon they have a
camera on her inside of discovery
and she does an interview as they're
getting ready to launch which gordo
watched
piscotty's friend called him out about
being too much of a pushover with ed and
that might be something that comes back
later he definitely is kind of awestruck
whenever he interacts with ed
and i can't imagine that they haven't
put that in there for a reason
another thing that was kind of strange
was the interactions with danny and
karen
it seems like maybe they're setting up
for him to have a crush on her
i can't imagine it going much further
than that but he was really excited that
she knew about wrestling and then later
we see her outside smoking weed and he
asked to take a hit
so that connects them in a way that
doesn't necessarily seem random they're
setting something
up there but i'm not sure what it is yet
some interesting stuff
kind of fascinating how all of these
three main characters who
spent all that time together on the moon
how things played out over the last nine
years for them
seeing where they're at right now in
light of that i think it makes sense for
danny to
get her own mission it's certainly a
ripple effect
but it's one that makes sense based on
what's happened in this timeline
i mentioned sally ride was the first
woman in 1983
the same year that we're in in the
alternate timeline
that's also when the first african
american was sent to space
and then we got the first black
commander in 1989 so things are moving
up in a natural pace here
i think this episode was on par with
what we've seen so far in season two
i thought the performances were really
great here and there were some really
strong sequences that get me hyped up
about seeing where things go towards the
end of the season
we've got ed in the ocean gordo
continuing to struggle
and i did like the insights into the
politics of keeping things moving with
the space program
by the time we get to season 3 nasa
might be financially autonomous
which could definitely lead to more
aggressive exploration and i like this
route better than the advancement of
private sector corporations taking
things
over in our own timeline also molly was
convinced to take over ed's position in
the astronaut office
after he helped her realize that she'd
be able to assign herself to pathfinder
down the road
there could definitely be consequences
for ed's dog fight could it be enough to
mess up his ride on pathfinder
like i said he lost a plane that
wouldn't probably be a big deal except
for he was doing something he wasn't
supposed to so he is
actually responsible for what happened
and the fact that he's in the water
it's gonna make for a rescue effort and
none of that had to happen
so we'll have to wait and see what it
leads to also with gordo we talked about
things from his perspective but he's
only there because ed thought it was the
best way to bring him out of his
funk payne brought this up whenever he
came to his office and called him out
and there's a definite possibility that
this wasn't the right idea
seeing him struggle trying to deal with
what gordo is going through
it doesn't really look great at this
point there was a mention of things
escalating in panama
the u.s launched a military rescue of
the four hostages there
and there's potential for things heating
up in the cold war
we'll see where that goes in light of
last week's decision to get guns on the
moon
and i think that's a good place to leave
things so let me know in the comments
what you thought about this episode
where you think things are going what
was your favorite scene
and what are you hoping to see next time
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching guys
i'll talk to you soon